Шановна пані роксулану На жаль ви не
поїхали з нами хоч ми запрошували на
лінію фронту зустрітися з військовими
підрозділами тоді б ви особисто побачили
Наскільки важко сьогодні і на
бахмутському на авдіївському на
запоріжському напрямках а в тому числі з
так званим контрнаступом а в цей час в
Києві іде гумористичний Контрнаступ
щодня Квартал 95 наступає в Жовтневому
палаці і таке інше і ви залишили в проек
бюджету на 24-й рік 440 млн на серіали
які парламент в принципі проголосував
направити на лікування наших військових
Як таке може бути в Ізраїлі міністр
інформатики інформації відмовився від
Міністерства його ліквідували і гроші
перерахували на армію чому в цьому
бюджеті ви підтримуєте 2 млрд на
брехливий олігархічний марафон